foreign College [Music]
McMichaels scores on the juicy rebound from
Carlson's chest shot off Omar Bruins are chasing
the score yeah not an ideal start for this Bruins
team and uh not really much to analyze on this
it's a Face-Off win in the offensive zone it's a
shot from the point that a rebound has led come
right back out in front of the goal the coverage
is loose the rebound available Nicholas Backstrom
oy clears zaka to poster knock plus
ice Ben Reeves like scores [Applause]
and McElroy able to get to a loose Puck first bat
it and direction of where the supports coming from
make sure it's hard and there's zaka picking up
that little touch pass you attack three on two
attack the middle of the Blue Line push the
puck wide and passenox with a great feed
to tape the van rheems like Nick down takes
it away and throws it past McAvoy facing Lowry
takes the hit to move the puck Jacob wauko
McAvoy hits the rush Lucic Dolores scores
having a hand in this goal Lori's got to get to
this Puck first he makes a play up the wall on the
back end absorbing the hit now the puck battle
begins the Wingers do their job along the wall
was able to force that punch to who
McAvoy who activates gain the line Lucy
slows down he becomes an option forward
is without his stick Matthew Phillips
Backstrom Wilson scores
sweet triangle from Backstrom to
kuznetsov the centering feed and
Wilson had time and space that's uh
Carlson certainly Wilson's going to
get open in that high slot it's a Well
executed triangle Backstrom I have a
great Playmakers entire career healthy now
get an opportunity to get real good NHL game
conditions with kuznetsov and Wilson and
you know on the entry Jacks Tom Wilson
a great back check effort by Macklemore Puck
loose in front kicked out by Omar and he has
it under the Trapper and rims like sets up
good back check by John Carlson's two on one
Sonny Milano with magical hands lifts the backhand
glove side on Old Mark and Washington leads 3-2
Carlson caught up ice now he's reading
it like a fold on a back check makes the
steal this is easy entry potential two on one
ends up being a three on two from close range
pretty soft hands there Sunny Milano didn't
really have an option right here I think that
pass Fireside is going to be taken away
by McAvoy so he went forehand backhand
he's younger brother helps Washington get
it out Anthony mantle it closes and
it's off grizzlick and off the putt
and deflected in by Milano
blalco's relentlessness and
Lucci tried to find Beecher
you're gonna get rewarded the phones have
been better here at Ferry too with straight
line hockey simplistic legs are moving people
are driving to the net a little exchange that
was kind of ugly in Center rice but they
just continue to pursue the puck [Music]
smartly chattan Kirk deloreai behind and
shredded the needle shot and Kirk moorized shot
gets it back [Applause]
across the face of the goal and Omar makes a
lunging save makes his save
on the rebound with his leg
a save and another by Omar
and Mason Laurie teamed up with Charlie McAvoy on
the back end looks real confident you know said it
early in the game you know he looks like a better
player when he plays with NHL caliber people seem
to fit more you know to that style which I totally
understand and totally get because that's off
has had a strong game Backstrom will rise shuts
down that seam and a tip by Tom Wilson or Nick
Backstrom [Music] it's Backstrom well former
tried to be real aggressive on the wall he
tried to chase down kuznetsov now you got
to try to recover and they're you know the
scramble's a little bit on and even though you
kind of get back into a box formation there's
too much time there's too much space there's
too many options for a quality power play Team
loses van Reems like Wilson's stick
forward in support Patra dangles and scores
whoa it's spectacular spin move out of the corner
and pots it so how tough It's been tonight going
against four experience centers he's hung
in there did the job in the Face-Off Circle
hasn't really created a ton offensively but
right here good play by forward to throw it down
deep one-on-one coverage spin away when the Caps
all grabs a different Bruin now that one-on-one
coverage is on his backside and he recognizes
that and he attacks the Nets that's kuznetsa
five seconds to go Tom Wilson spins it malinstein
and the siren sounds we go till overtime
Tom Wilson and John Carlson three on
three five minutes of sudden death
Carlson took his Nets off to Marshawn Wilson
a Same by Omar and Wilson has his stick in
the air and the washout oh looks like
the buck is still under yeah [Applause]
Same by Kemper Carlson Tim Phillips
Phillips scores
Matthew Phillips Stands Tall the smallest player
on the ice tonight wins it for watching Team